[Music]
so I think all this is an interesting
Segway - jamele Hill which will kind of
get us into ESPN in general and again
again all these things are so related
from from the what the individual is
doing to the employer - now the
companies and everything else and we can
talk about Trump and all that but you're
Mel is an interesting one I would love
to have her yeah on the show she's
welcome to come on she said you know
this thing about Trump being a white
supremacist now I don't agree with the
premise but I do defend her right so she
what she wants of course but that comes
with the risk that you're talking about
your employer may not be that thrilled
then a couple weeks go by and then she
want speech she's actively telling
people to boycott ESPN's advertisers
that is at to me that is as fireable of
an offense as you could possibly have as
an employee of a company telling the
people who pay the bills they don't it's
AI think goes to an a lack of
comprehension about how you're paid
right because ultimately I understand
you guys figure out how the business
model is funded and she said boycott
AT&T AT&T provides 15 percent of the
revenue of ESPN through DirecTV plus all
their sundry other advertisements that
they that they pay to me the Jamel he'll
mess was set in place by a prior
decision which was a wrong one and I'm a
First Amendment absolutist we said
before I love first and Eminem boobs
yeah and I think what's a little bit
scary about the First Amendment and why
a lot of people follow us is in a modern
social media era you even if you're off
your job can be fired for something that
you put on Facebook or that you put on
Twitter or Instagram or snapchat it's
it's an instant from going being no name
at all to being virally famous and
that's a great book you probably have
read it so you've been publicly shamed I
think it was John I I know that I
haven't read it
oh it's so good but a lot of it is what
we live right and so it's fine for
people like you or me because we have a
little bit of public profile so if
somebody decides oh clay Travis said
something controversial and comes after
me well there's people who know me and
are gonna defend me if you're just a
regular person there's probably not very
many people who are gonna defend you it
turns into a mob really quickly and so I
think this is emblematic of larger
society as a whole I think it's a little
bit scary that people are constantly
being judged by what they say on so
Media as it pertains to their job I
don't know why everybody suddenly works
in HR in our immediate reaction when
somebody says something you don't like
whatever political side you're on is
that person should be fired really funny
like you do you wake up and you look at
Twitter and I'm like all right who today
that I've never heard of before is gonna
be a star is going to either a star
we're just gonna be like you know
publicly shamed or destroyed in hardened
feather
yes but it's her way what was the what
was the decision so the first decision
that was wrong was Curt Schilling Curt
Schilling went on his private Facebook
page when he was not on air and like I
make this distinction I think some
people follow it some people don't
if Jamel Hill goes on 6 p.m.
SportsCenter and she says the Rockets
won last night and oh by the way Donald
Trump's a white supremacist and all the
supporters are racist she should be
fired yeah because that's ESPN using
their method of distribution to reach
all of their audience and people go on
there expecting that they're not going
to hear about Donald Trump being a white
supremacist and and the same thing would
be true of Curt Schilling Curt Schilling
got fired because he had done several
things the conservative but he had said
he chaired a meme which basically
ridiculed the North Carolina transgender
bathroom right and it was like a popular
meme on the internet that lots of people
were sharing like something about like a
guy who was dressed up like a woman like
let him use the bathroom with your
daughter whatever and again I don't have
an issue with the try I think this is a
great example of how we manufacture
issues that shouldn't exist somehow in
the 60s the 70s will right movement the
rest of the 60s the 70s 80s 90s 2000s
2000 teens people who are dressed like
one sex to use that bathroom and we've
never had any people have been going to
the bathroom I have heard a lot of
problems about it never had any issue
the example I use is we don't have
somebody Crocodile Dundee gender Jenna
wins and outside right yeah so that's a
Sheila gives it a chance yeah yeah it
may be so and so I don't think his
opinion was irrational I don't think it
was outlandish I think it was certainly
permissible because in his private life
that's what he believes they fired him
for it and I think once they fired him
for that they established there are
private opinions that ESPN employees can
have which don't allow them to have
public opinions on
world of sports curt schilling wasn't
fired because he did a bad job analyzing
whether the Red Sox should change relief
pitchers right he wasn't fired because
he said something on the air that was
bad for ESPN's business he was fired
because people decided to follow his
private political opinions and deem them
to be unacceptable my issue with the
ESPN is not politics it's that they have
decided that only left-wing politics are
permissible
so when Jamel Hill says that the
president is a white supremacist that
his supporters are all racist and that
everybody that surrounds him is also
white supremacists including by the way
potentially his his daughter who is
Jewish and his grand I don't think there
that's wife who is in him yes yes I
don't think there that many people who
would marry an immigrant and also be
very comfortable with having
grandchildren who are Jewish that are
just fundamentally vile human beings who
judge based on race gender religion
whatever so when she gives that opinion
they have set the precedent of you could
be fired for a political opinion they
don't do anything for that opinion they
basically wrapper on her knuckles say
she shouldn't have done that and it
clearly establishes what I've been
writing and talking about for a long
time which is ESPN has one standard of
speech for left-wing political belief
and another standard for right-wing and
to me that's emblematic not just of ESPN
but of our culture as a whole when it
comes frequently to the world of sports
media which I'm in yeah I don't think
you're an awful human being if you
disagree with the with you know the fact
that Charlotte has a rule about
transgender bathroom right I think it's
stupid that we end up in this debate
because again it's a fundamentally
artificial debate designed to play to
the basis of the left and the right and
create conflict where we don't need it
but I don't think you having one opinion
or the other there is an awful one I
think it's an artificial construct and I
don't think that ESPN can make the
decision oh because of this we're
pulling our games our all-star game out
of the City of Charlotte and the same
thing of the ACC and all these other
sports media leviathans that did that
and then you're also by the way playing
games in Mexico which has much worse of
a human rights issues and and violations
when it comes to gays MVAs got games in
China which doesn't even allow people to
get on you know like the
Internet and use it freely we're
building or not we but Qatar is building
the World Cup Stadium for whatever it is
slave labor with slave labor literally
yes and also all these it's not just
athletics by the way it's all these
people who are musicians they come out
and say oh we're not gonna play in North
Carolina but then they're playing in
Latvia no no like literally like then
they are playing for Saudi Arabia which
just now allowed women to drive cars
yeah right like it's it's a artificial
outrage machine that isn't rooted in any
kind of reality and I think sports has
become one of the driving forces of it
so how do we take some of this back yeah
it's a great thing queer doing it I
think conversations like this are
actually doing it as we were saying
there's people taking the red pill yeah
yeah but where does this where does this
put you even politically actually I
don't because if we if we were to go
through a couple of things you you sir
everything up completely honestly no
answer me ask me any question I'll give
you the I had you know I never yes my my
guests a question beforehand but I had
no doubt because that's one of the
things that I get criticized about like
I turned down my own television show to
be able to say exactly what I think
right I think the most illegitimate you
can attack my beliefs and as much as you
want I'm wide open to that the most
illegitimate thing that people say about
me is clay Travis is just saying that
because he wants to get attention
because he's trying to sell to a Marc no
I have literally turned down millions of
dollars to be able to say exactly what I
believe my ability to tell you exactly
what I think is to me the most important
thing that I do and I'm to the extent
like everybody sells out on some level
like I don't know how many people who
are in my industry would turn down their
own television show so they can still
sell everybody what they think about
Game of Thrones which I was told I
couldn't talk about as well as every
political belief I've ever had
so yeah fire away I mean I think this is
a fascinating well just for the record
I've had at least three offers for
networks for more money than I'm making
and I've said no to because yes as you
said I'm the home studio I have a home
studio
nobody is controlling us there is
nothing in our ear yes it doesn't mean
we're gonna be right all the time
but what it means is we're gonna be real
or at least as real as humanly possible
[ __ ] in America right now then I think
what matters more than anything else
regardless of what you believe is that
you are authentically in what you
believe and that you know people who are
watching this in a conversation between
the two of us
think they'll say wow like that sounds
like a real conversation that real
people are having as opposed to like you
said somebody in our ear talking for
three minutes and telling us what to say
they're creating artificial debate so I
sense that you're probably right where I
am in that I think you're probably a
classical liberal I don't know that
you've I know you voted for Garry
Johnson this past time as I did to both
said yeah a little checkoff of anything
I've ever done I've had him on the show
he's a perfectly nice guy but yeah
terrible candidate okay again we both
went over was that he was gonna be a lot
better than he was
yeah that there would have been a viable
option there as opposed to the two most
hated candidates that have ever been
nominated by major political parties in
our country's history I'm with you
brother okay so so he was a libertarian
yeah obviously
so I sense that you're somewhere between
probably a classical liberal and a
libertarian I don't even think defense
you know defining them so perfectly is
that important but you mentioned a
couple a little bit of your liberal cred
so you want to just knock off a couple
Roach oice okay I think that you should
have that right if you're a woman to
decide whether or not to have a baby
i amber grudgingly Pro I'll even go
further than that I really struggle with
it but at the moment I am pro-choice I
am when it comes to the death penalty
because I've I've worked in the criminal
justice system I think the death penalty
presumes a level of certitude that does
not exist I think it presumes that we
are flawless I think we're all flawed no
matter what we do for a living I think
there probably have been innocent people
put to death for crimes they did not
commit and I think if you or I were
accused of murder we wouldn't get the
death penalty because we're wealthy
enough to afford good attorneys so I
think if you are poor and likely to be
not represented by a quality attorney
you're more likely to get the death
penalty so I think that's an unfair
aspect of it as well okay so against the
death penalty pro-choice for gay
marriage we got that marriage I am I
would say from a I wish there was a lot
less tax you know like I am pro markets
I think one thing you learn early on at
least for me when I went to law school
and I went to work at a firm and started
representing big companies I was blown
away by the false and like just crap
lawsuits that are filed all day long
every day mm-hmm there are good lawsuits
that need to be filed against big
companies the vast majority don't and so
I am I don't believe that companies are
evil you know I believe in markets
I'm a First Amendment absolutist I
believe in the marketplace of ideas it's
funny
I got a D in First Amendment law when I
was a back
Vanderbilt Law School you're making up
for it I can afford now it's I never
would have believed that I would end up
you know as fascinated by the law and
studying it now you know when I was 22
it was a third year 25 I guess in the
third year my final semester I didn't
buy books and I didn't go to class like
I was I was ready to just take the bar
exam and be out and so I got a D on that
first amendment exam but I wish now I
could go back in time and more seriously
study it because I've ended up doing it
as an adult but I wish I had gotten that
found date I wish I paid more attention
when I was 25 so kids out there pay more
attention in class even if you're
thinking like I'm never gonna use this
because who makes a living talking about
the First Amendment somehow probably of
anybody at Vanderbilt Law School I bet I
spend more time talking about it than
anybody well it's funny right before we
started I said to you that I went to
SUNY Binghamton yeah we didn't have a
great athletic program right right which
I would have been very into so I really
just smoke pot and play video games for
four years I was a Poli Sci major so I
guess I parlayed that into something but
yeah I I go to these schools now and I
was at Clemson last Mia's at Harvard two
weeks ago and I go to all these schools
and I need all these kids who are so in
the thick of it figuring out what they
think and we're talking about all this
stuff and I'm like man you have such a
leg up on the world it's so great it's
inspiring well I'm impressed by the
number of college kids that are like
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on right
now yeah you know and and they're like
really kind of steeped in it because
they are on a college campus right now
and they see this like what I what I
call is like it's not like a modern-day
royalty because you'll hear like back in
the day you you would hear if you were
in England somebody would say I'm the
3rd Earl Dorchester you know like they
run all the different titles right as a
way to legitimize whatever their opinion
is yeah nowadays on college campus
somebody's like I'm a you know black
lesbian transgender before they even say
their opinion they gotta have a limp -
yeah a limp as a black lesbian
transgender male female like whatever
you want to say like before they get to
their opinion I'm like why do I care
about the prelude like is your argument
good or is it bad and we were talking
about this affair - when you get
attacked by an accusation of something
that you know you're not to me I just
kind of smile because it means I won the
argument
so when you saw that piece it was
political right yeah so when you saw
that piece as I said I saw the headline
I knew I didn't even have to read it and
I could already see a little bit
action picking up and and again as you
said earlier it's great when you have
people defending you yes because it
allows you to breathe it allows you to
move on we could spend all day long it
was a five tap so there's been it's
funny there's that like daily beast did
like a 5,000 word piece on me mm-hmm and
I talked to them and then Politico did a
5,000 word piece and I talked to them
what was the title or what did they
exactly say that you're the all rights
hero or something like that now again we
just laid out some of your liberal or
libertarian cred I have yet to hear you
I assume at some point you're gonna
burst that with some sort of racist yeah
it's like but I mean again it's
important to frame it that way yeah
because I see this I mean I've seen it
happen to me I've had several articles
written in the same I'm further um
further to the extreme right than
Breitbart I mean yeah just abject
dribble and that's why we lay out what
we say and then it's like they don't
people here don't care people don't
listen they don't care they already have
their preconceived notions and so I mean
my writers I'm talking about the writers
my editors yeah they came and they spent
you know like the guy came and he spent
the day with me I start every morning
people don't know at 4:00 a.m. I get up
really early cuz I've got an early
morning sports talk show that I do from
6 to 9 a.m. Eastern and then I do a show
also on periscope and Facebook live at 3
o'clock Eastern everyday and then I
write in between that time I do all this
I'm fortunate you know like I own 100
percent of my company like like you the
business side of things allows me to be
as outspoken as I am in a way frankly
that I wouldn't be if I was reliant upon
being an employee of a major media
company yeah do you find that you're
able to put these principles that you
talked about into practice for your
business too yeah cuz that's one of the
things that's very cool for me the
things that I believe in yes when I talk
about low taxes and yeah and treating
people right and all of those things
those are the ways that I operate my
business so it makes the views that I
talked about stronger action yes I don't
think there's anybody that I've ever
worked with who would come out and say a
negative word about me you know that's
like my wife says that I'm unique in
that people attacking me doesn't bother
me and it's almost like if you watch
football defensive backs get burned yeah
give up a touchdown pass the next drive
they're right back up on the line of
scrimmage talk line of scrimmage talking
trash and you have to have no memory to
play that position I don't like hole
grudge
is I do I just kind of let things go I'm
very like kind of karmic in that way and
I don't think you could do my job if you
set around and worry like my wife says
you can get ten things negative said
about you and you remember the positive
right I mean and and I do think there's
a little bit of truth to that but yeah
it's like I and I always said if people
who know me well I think I said that
backwards or we do this very differently
yes does she say that you can say ten
things negative and you remember the
positive or the other way around me it's
like I get 10 positives but the only one
I read no I'm exactly the opposite okay
wow you are doing it doesn't really
register I almost feel like when I do
the radio show it's almost it's my way
of sitting down and getting to have
therapy without actually having to pay
for therapy that's incredible and that's
very the reverse about what a lot of
people public people are because I have
so many people that come on and talk
about that I forget all the good stuff
and you know it's I don't necessarily
marinate it so it's almost like it's
just noise yeah you know it doesn't
impact there's nothing that somebody's
gonna say to me that's gonna change my
opinion about something and that's one
of the funniest things about Twitter is
I'll make an argument and then somebody
will be like oh did you think about X Y
or Z and yeah I did and my wife is gonna
be an issue because she's really smart
obviously too and I would talk about her
with an opinion and I'd ask her opinion
I might not take her advice and she
would say why did you ask me my opinion
and then not take it it's because I want
to talk to as many smart people as I can
make sure that I've considered every
angle there's a great line from another
Tennessee and I used to say Davy
Crockett used to say be sure you're
right then go ahead it's actually pretty
good advice right I mean like if you
think through everything in a rigorous
manner by the time I go public with my
opinion I've kind of thought through it
so yeah like I I think that in general
there are very few people who actually
look at the facts and apply them to a
set of principles do I defend a Jamel
Hill I said she shouldn't get suspended
same principle that I apply when I said
with Curt Schilling he shouldn't get
suspended
most people decide whether or not they
like speech based on whether they agree
with it Colin Kaepernick it's the
easiest thing to do we're all for free
speech and then and then somebody says
something you don't like but imagine
Colin Kaepernick takes a knee and says
that the reason he's doing it is because
he opposes gay marriage nobody in San
Francisco or
the left wing is gonna say have an issue
at all if the 49ers cut it mm-hmm right
that's his political speech and actually
makes sense because the United States
flag represents gay marriage being
allowed now whereas the United States
flag doesn't represent based on the
actions taken by the government the idea
that police should be able to kill
minorities with impunity in fact the
exact opposite which is what I said
earlier like he's protesting something
the government's already trying to take
action against so all this said so now
these articles Garen's yeah the
political piece and again people defend
against all that stuff so basically
you're just saying you just gotta let it
roll off your back and not do anything
right because I mean a lot of people
asked me about this thing because I
think that there's so many people that
watch the two of us or listen to us yeah
that want to get in this fight but
they're afraid because they don't have
the yeah public profile that we have or
whatever it is we don't have the the
Twitter followers that are gonna back
them up and all that so I think it's an
important thing like to discuss how we
navigate through that well so I
appreciate first of all everybody who
stood up and said that article was
[ __ ] was disappointing to me is I
brought that guy into my house yep I
think he spent all day with me I said I
start at 4 a.m. he spent all day with me
he saw exactly what I did I don't worry
about what I say cuz people who are
watching and listening this right now I
probably said 40,000 words you know I've
been very triggered the entire time by
the way but I say so much that it's hard
to pull one thing out and say oh my god
clay Travis said this now boobs in First
Amendment might might change because
that exposed me to an audience they
didn't know I existed
but I'd let him talk to my producer on
my radio show and my wife and I think
that he said he chose I don't think I
know talk to my wife for a half hour
and he takes the two most negative
things that she says and turns it into
like a story he takes things that my
producer said that we're not true and he
wrote about it and I think for those
people who don't have a public persona
already I feel worse about a situation
like that and I also feel like in the
future as more writers are writing about
me to the extent that I even want to
participate in them I need to just pull
my own phone out hire a transcript
person and let them put every word that
I said on the record and go read the
transcript as opposed to pulling out
because I think you know this I don't
think the average person does the quotes
that you choose
tells more about you frequently than it
does about the person you're trying to
profile so I was hopeful Politico is a
big-name place I thought maybe they'll
do a really nuanced intelligent
portrayal about the conflict between
sports and politics and this guy who has
somehow found himself in the center of
them who used to be in democratic
politics now identify I call myself a
radical moderates somewhere in the
middle which I wish there were more
people like us and I think there are
there are there but they don't get paid
attention to because they're not on the
fringes creating a stir every day and so
I thought maybe this would be a really
good profile and I was just disappointed
because it was lazy it was a profile
that was written with preconceived
notions already in mind but within two
days its watering the bridge and I think
the reason is because the reason why I
do that I get involved in those is
people think when they share something
and say this guy's an [ __ ] that all
their friends are gonna agree with them
what I have found is if you go on social
media and you say Clay Travis is the
worst human being ever seventy percent
of people who follow you may agree
thirty percent of people click on it
that we like know what kind of agree
with a little bit what he's saying I
might not be saying it publicly but
there are so many people out there who
don't feel comfortable saying things and
then that 30% turns into my allies the
70 percent who you're sharing like if
somebody already hates me yeah 70
percent of their audience robably gonna
hate me otherwise but where we've grown
is not by people just it's by
word-of-mouth who people who like us
sharing it with their audience right but
it's also by people who hate us sharing
that I do and then some of their people
that they think they're their natural
allies they might even be talking with
you at a dinner party even like I hate
clay Travis but in reality you know
they're they're reading the articles
they might be sharing them with other
friends who are like mind and it's like
you have to hide sometimes yeah and
what's so interesting is that when they
do it to a guy like you and they'll be
like ah he's this all right yeah he's
just whatever then you read the whole
article you can't get a quote where it
actually said any of that and then
actually they do push people more your
way so it really it's sort of this it's
a self self-fulfilling prophecy and
again it just comes back to if you're
attacking somebody instead of their
ideas you lose
the first person to decide Oh Clay
Travis reminds me of Nazis that person
lost the argument right and I just think
that that is the the default of the left
now yeah well I appreciate you not
wearing the Nazi head because he came in
and you were just off the plane and by
the way it's cyclical
yeah it'll you know back when Bill Maher
got fired it was if you weren't a
hardcore patriot the right is defending
free speech right now but the great
thing about America is as long as free
speech is protected there's always gonna
be people like you and I who may not fit
particular political disciplines and all
the people out there listening and
watching right now but understand that
our most important right is the right to
disagree absolutely that's how you end
an interview and I feel like right true
we feel like we barely scratched the
surface we had your whole day with you I
mean I really I mean I love what you do
you do great work I appreciate you
having me in thanks well I feel the same
way and it's like I feel like we just
had to do just like some cleanup so next
time you're in LA there's so many other
things we can get into you were talking
about Disney CEO Bob Iger running for
president you've been talking about for
a long time and I think you're right
he's catching up with it and a whole
bunch of other stuff and I know you've
run into crawler I'm doing Carolla
tomorrow so don't don't just don't
Oh totally blow it yawn yes leave a
little free speed yes for me for more
like late tune into out kick the
coverage on Fox Sports Radio and follow
him on the Twitter at Clay Travis
[Music]
you